we're going to begin this hour with some
of the entertainment world's biggest
celebrities sharing their very personal
health stories in a new series on
Paramount plus it's called the checkup
with Dr David Aegis and it's really
really good yes what kind of stars are
we talking about well Ashton Kutcher
Howie Mandel Oprah Winfrey and Maria
Shriver are just some of the stars in
the first three episodes sharing their
own struggles with our Dr Aegis and the
goal here is to help others feel less
alone here's a sample of again just the
first three episodes
I woke up one day and like was having
Vision issues could hardly see knocked
out my hearing which threw off my
equilibrium and my balance and I
couldn't walk and I had vasculitis in
November of 2019 my patient Ashton
Kutcher was diagnosed with vasculitis a
serious autoimmune disease that attacks
the blood vessels it can cause
significant medical problems including
organ damage there's a standard you
become accustomed to in your life like
being able to see clearly with intensive
treatment at a hospital a very lucky
Ashton Kutcher has made a remarkable
recovery something he appreciates
because of his brother this is the first
interview he's ever done with his twin
Michael who was born with Cerebral Palsy
then at 13 Michael developed an
unrelated heart condition that nearly
took his life suddenly my dad comes
picks me up and it's like you're gonna
go see your brother
and I'm like this is not okay this is
everything is not okay
[Music]
and
and he flat lines in the room and I'm
like what the hell is going like I had
no idea if I'd if I'd come out or or not
I looked out in the street and it was
just teeming with people in New York and
the and the traffic and everything and I
thought I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
run out into traffic it was really
really really bad while laughter is a
Salvation Howie Mandel battles with
obsessive-compulsive disorder a mental
health disorder featuring a pattern of
unwanted thoughts and fears obsessions
and his daughter Jacqueline who also
struggles with her mental health Cheryl
zuetto is like to have a father with OCD
it wasn't until I was around High School
age when I had friends come over and
tell me that my dad is crazy or weird or
different what was really hard was
realizing that it wasn't me oh so we're
talking about the Big M today I love
this listen it's horribly branded right
menopause as a word yes we call it the
Big M yeah or the menopause Revolution
Oprah Winfrey and Maria Shriver are on a
mission to change the way women prepare
for menopause I was like in my late 40s
and having heart palpitations going to
every doctor and every night I have
journals filled with I don't know if
I'll make it till the morning nobody
ever once suggested that that it could
be menopause right
and CBS News medical contributor Dr
David Aegis joins us now uh Dr Aegis
you've got three fans of this program uh
right here and I think I get to ask the
first question lucky me I think what I'm
Amazed by the most is you know it's hard
to get a celebrity to talk about their
latest project right to have them
talking about their health issues how
did you do that well thank you Tony for
the kind words you know I'm a doctor and
so I think part of it is they know I'm
going to stay in my Lane they know it's
going to be a meaningful conversation
about health it's not going to be a
celebrity it's not to men grab headlines
it really is meant to help other people
and they're Heroes for stepping up and
being so vulnerable it really is kind of
I will Echo what Tony said number one I
tended just to watch one episode to get
a feel for it it is so damn good because
number one they're very candid with you
they clearly feel safe with you you know
all the right questions to ask but what
is your hope that people will get out of
this because I felt like celebrities are
just like us they have the same medical
issues and concerns yeah well that's it
we do the purpose of this series is
really to show people that we all have
medical issues every single person in
this country no matter who you are no
matter where you live no matter how much
you make no matter the color of your
skin we all have medical issues to
normalize that is important to enable
the conversations why are you hide that
you're suffering let your friends and
family support you on a show like this
can educate people about that and about
the individual diseases Disease by
disease so but that's tricky David we
just heard about the news with Kirstie
Alley her family still hasn't said what
the cancer was so we still don't know
the exact cause of it it's Chadwick
Boseman died we didn't even know that he
was suffering so this is still so
whatever your medical issue is it's
still so hard to talk about yeah no
question about it we put these things
into a closet and we need your own route
you look at Oprah the smartest woman in
the country and she didn't know she was
going through menopause and thought that
literally this was the end of her life
something was going wrong well that's
not right you have to demystify these
things and she was going to the best
doctors too I remember when this was
happening she was going the best doctors
and and wasn't getting the help we are
not taught about menopause in medical
school right there's no thing on that in
high school you know you're talking
about biology chemistry you're not
taught about cancer Alzheimer's and and
heart disease yeah we need to educate
people on those Ashton Kutcher he was
sitting there with his twin uh gripping
hands and he opened up about a
life-threatening autoimmune disease and
then his twin talked about almost dying
what stood out to you in that
conversation you know just to watch that
and Ashton saying you know I know he
needed a match I know he had days to
live this was his brother was the first
person to go on a heart lung bypass
machine and literally had 48 hours to
get a match of a heart so it was the
lottery and he won and Ashton is saying
I'm looking at a balcony saying if I
jump from that balcony I know I'm a
match and I could save my brother's life
Wow think about that it was just but
David can I say one more thing about
this series produced by the great Susan
zorinsky who was beloved here in this
building but in in the middle of giving
these interviews you also give us
information the thing that stood out to
me with the conversation that you had
one percent of what percent of longevity
is genetic and you said it's only four
percent ninety six percent is what we do
I always thought
it's shocking and if you live closer to
an airport how it affects your brain so
in the middle of all of these interviews
great conversations you're also
sprinkling information
so good it's also very interesting but
this is the secret right I want to use
the power celebrity and slip in
information to empower people about
their own health not just about disease
but how living well living long and
living you know with all of the data
that we have I want people to benefit
from it to prevent disease and that's
what's such a privilege is to get that
information to people because they oh
they all got something I'll bet other
people reach out to you yeah um and we
have I mean just in the last couple days
the people reaching out saying I want to
tell my story I've been really exciting
and uh because they know you're not
going to ask did you sleep with someone
so unless it's medically real yes
and I yes it's probably not going to be
anything related scenario or not
yourself apart
Great series those are just the first
three episodes we're talking about and
by the way if you want to catch them uh
the first three episodes of the checkup
with Dr David Aegis they're going to be
available to stream today on Paramount
plus which like CBS itself is a division
of Paramount global